jojo was geht hier soll max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video heute seht
ihr vielleicht bin ich in einer
ungewohnten umgebung desaster und was
macht man wenn man einer ungewohnten
umgebung ist und sie zu erkunden
richtig man spielt vor kümmern glaube
ich bin jetzt im sommer urlaub an der
nordsee
naja man sagt ja so zum beispiel das
wasser pokémon vermehrt am meer
vorkommen und deshalb achten wir gehen
wir mal direkt ans meer und zwar an den
strand und suchen nach ein paar pokemons
war die karte anschauen
hier ist ein bisschen was in der nähe
allerdings desto näher man als mehr
kommt desto weniger ist da eigentlich
wären hier unten am meer einen fotostopp
den werden wir uns gleich mal raussuchen
und da vorbeischauen wir können jetzt
schon mal abholen
wir sagen wir springen einfach mal
runter an den strand
leute da vorne ist das meer wir sind
kurz davor
bisher sind noch keine puppe und
begegnet aber wir geben natürlich nicht
auf und laufen mal vorschlagen was da
geht es los angeles spielte leute ihr
seht schon ist es hier nicht nur unserer
windig sondern wir sind auch so gut wie
direkt am meer wir machen das jetzt so
wir laufen direkt am meer entlang die
linie
total opel antrags wenn man direkt am
meer irgendwie sogar anfangen können
oder so die laufen einfach mal anschauen
was finden ansonsten habe ich auch noch
was vorbereitet
ich werde hier circa weggepustet ich
hoffe ihr habt mich trotzdem guck mal
springen hoch
ich bin also doch eigentlich ist es sehr
idyllisch hier es fehlen nur die pokémon
weiß und breit nicht wirklich was zu
finden sind noch alle arenen von team
rot sonst würde ich einfach mal im video
einer einnehmen aber ich bin ja selbst
team rot von daher hätte guck mal der
wind der junge krass das gibt's doch
nicht mehr weiter leute ich habe ein
gefühl habe hinter diesem turm ist ein
pokémon versteckt wer will kann ich mir
ziemlich sicher ist was könnte das sein
was wir in koffern versteckt sich in der
rettungsstation la paz oder hier auch in
lotte ausgelacht ja sie dahinter ist
garantierten la presse
das war nicht angezeigt ob in der nähe
aber es wundert mich dass wir keinen von
den freunden habe ich meine wir sind
immerhin im land das ist einfach kein
sondern hier aber egal wir uns jetzt la
paz leute
fast gleichauf zu müssen ist leise sein
damit wir das la paz nicht aufwecken
weil bekannterweise schlafen la praxis
hinter rettungsstation
ich habe euch gesagt ich würde das
finden das ist la paz er für extras ja
meine forschung nach dabei wirklich guck
mal hier rein hätte es gibt hier nicht
ist so richtig gestört
neulich habe ich gesagt ich hatte so ein
gefühl dass ihr das live band ist
schlagartig luft sichere helú
aber egal wir schreiten vor zu plan
nummer zwei und dafür müssen wir da
vorgehen
und um diesen zweiten plan zu vollziehen
muss ich mir leider poker points kaufen
wirklich zum allerersten mal muss ich
das tun
aber bei mir ist das problem gar nicht
habe nur 20 pkt coins ich bin level 22
38.000 ep und ich gehe zum ersten mal
was aus für das spiel aber für dieses
video also wenn ihr es cool findet lass
mal leichter kopf kopf kopf danke ihr kv
erfolgreich so so und jetzt fragt ihr
euch bestimmt was kauft der dude mit
diesem punkt können natürlich ich zeige
es euch
wir laufen straight auf ein poker module
zu und wenn ihr mal vergleicht die rote
2 ihr seht ihr auf dem bild und wenn wir
mal bisschen drüber schwenkt hier ist
die rote zwei das heißt wir steuern
darauf zu fangen wir zeit mit einem lock
modul unsere pokémon am strand aber was
soll's wenigstens haben wir dann am
strand so leute jetzt wird erstmal das
lockt modul gekauft
barbara etwas schiefgegangen was ist
schief gegangen komme und ich hab grad
geld ausgegeben
was soll ich gehe es erstmal wieder raus
und rein aus der app ja aber ich hoffe
wirklich wirklich zum ersten mal geld
ausgegeben dass das jetzt nicht nicht
packt okay wir sind drin shop modul
einlösen moment warte ja ok das heißt es
hat funktioniert leute 3po quelle top
wir setzen uns mal der forst in
containern lockt modulreihen kann man um
ein korb heute fast so gut wie ein
garros
jetzt fehlen mir nur noch 80 kaddor bis
ist entwickeln kann
so leute und während wir erwarten dass
noch ein zwei pokémon spawnen dachte ich
mir zeige ich euch einfach mal was
bisher meine besten pokémon sind und
vielleicht die geschichten wie wir sie
gefangen haben also meine nummer eins
und gleichzeitig mein ganzer stolz
hakkani also direkt erstmalig habe die
nicht entwickelt arcania sondern habe
ihn so gefangen
wir sind einfach zu viert durch die
stadt gefahren und haben so gesehen
akari boots direkt alle raus aus dem
auto hingegangen und ultra hype gewesen
dass wir den gefangen haben ist auch
unter den zehn besten pokémon in ganz
pokémon bau und sehr sehr nice ok nummer
zwei
agrana agrana ist ein klassiker also
nicht schwer zu bekommen aber ultra
stark leute mit zwischenzeitlich schwer
ausgesprochen und zwar einen muchas
empfangen wir uns mal eben 164 der
lancken poker ball so der ob
dort treffen so ich muss schauen ob ich
vielleicht bald entwickeln kann
nein 14 muss als bonbon fehlen mir noch
okay leute mein nächstes pokémon ist
relax- so also galaxis ja schon wieder
eher ein exot kann man sagen ich habe
schon einmal ein power up durchgeführt
bei redaktor und 1413 also der ist
einfach ultra stark die da war ich so
hype vor allem gebt euch mal die zweite
attacke erdbeben hat einfach 100 es ist
so gestört redaktion des echten kranker
kinder
ich saß gerade im auto und museen ok
relax- und dann dachte wirklich ich
schaue poken ist poken vision war dauern
und ich bin einfach mal ein ganz
normaler weg nach hause gefahren weil
ich mir dachte okay du kannst sowieso
keinen sinn wenn der step back noch da
ist und bin einfach mein weg gefahren
und nach einer halben minute ist einfach
der typ auf meiner karte leute ihr könnt
euch nicht vorstellen wie cool das war
gestoppt können wir wieder abholen
so leute mein viertbestes pokémon magna
auch sehr dogma ist allerdings leider
hat mich so viel potenzial wie die
anderen
und zu guter letzt ein hübner auf nummer
5 also seiten sehr gut was leute hier
sind tot und ich habe noch nie gesehen
ich hoffe du du du du bist 514 514
alters es ist das allererste mal dass
die doku-serie leute haben
trotz allen leids leute das hätte ich
nicht gedacht also mein krieg
tatsächlich am meer beziehungsweise halt
an anderen orten pokémon die man sonst
noch nie gesehen hat weil level 22 und
noch nie so gesehen ist irgendwie auch
bisschen strange aber 50 braucht zum
entwickeln leider begebt euch mal das du
bist fast max taut ihr seht ihr diesen
weißen balken das ist fasst max taut das
wird richtig krass also generell hier
nochmal eine übersicht über meine besten
pokémon also ich habe eine ganz stabile
aufstellung ich habe blut sicher wasser
ich habe feuer ich hab psycho ich habe
normal also es ist eigentlich sehr
stabil soireen gehen auch immer ganz gut
damit
aber was mich ein bisschen stört ist
dass ich keine ultras pokémon habe leute
wir erwarten uns noch einen pokémon ab
aber es wird gerade wirklich wirklich
kalt weil die sonne jetzt weg ist wer
vorne ist ein möbius kunstwerken
irgendwie ich hoffe ja dass benutzt die
schaufel
bankchef
menden
erwin leuthe es ist nichts geringeres
als ein rockiges ventoux
es ist sozusagen das zeichen das ist ja
auch das alte bayerische sprichwort
siehst du auch gehst du fährst fucking
drei leute hält der schwede okay wenn
man highlights im business das war es
vom vielleicht ersten pokémon go video
aus dem urlaub ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen dass mal ein blockmodell da und
bis zum nächsten mal tschüss